repeat myself myself myself we're stuck
in a timeless something really bizarre
is happening Oh Hedgehog Day Groundhog
Day
what's that Pete my saga most highly
ready repeat myself we're stuck in a
time loop there was a wolf coming and he
Street needs you to be ready so where do
we start
let's do this ready
[Music]
we're good we got the right stuff DC's
legends of tomorrow Mondays at 8:00
hey everybody it's Charlie legends
finally has the right stuff and the
right stuff just happens to be Wally
West I love the way they work him in at
the end of that promo to like that's
from the first episode but he's credited
on episode 11 which is next week's
episode so I'll explain what's going on
because it involves that twist from the
end of last week's episode where rip
hunter had mysteriously escaped from his
time bureau prison so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos because
wally west is on for the rest of the
season on legends of tomorrow so I will
be doing videos for those episodes and I
will be doing that blast ring giveaway
too but remember it's a Monday night
show now too so bit of a change in the
schedule but I think if anybody's been
hiding under a rock during the Olympics
they probably figured it out after last
week's episode the big thing they're
doing this week is Groundhog's Day like
they make the Hedgehog's day joke but
with the white snake song title here I
go again which is from the 80s which is
weird because they're all dressed up
like they're inside staying alive during
the 70's so they're mixing and matching
a lot of genres but just to make another
flash grodd pun it seems like they're
aping that episode of Star Trek where
the enterprise would blow up at the end
of a time loop over and over again and
Captain Picard had to figure out what
was going on somehow we've entered what
seems to be a temporal causality loop we
think we're stuck in a specific fragment
in time that we've been repeating that
same fragment I think it's called cause
and effect so I'm expecting lots of Star
Trek Easter eggs but rip hunter is the
person who was supposed to get Wally
West and bring him into present-day
they're wearing all that 70s gear they
even posted this behind-the-scenes video
of them doing a fake music video for
staying alive I can't play it here
because I think the music is heavily
copyrighted I don't think they actually
pony up the cash to pay the license fee
to use the music in the episode music
tracks from other artists are actually
really expensive to use depending on
what production you are like all the
Kendrick music that made it into Black
Panther his label charged Marvel and
Disney a dumptruck of money to use that
but because this is a zari centric
episode I wouldn't be surprised if she's
the one that resolves that story
and then Wally West shows up so I don't
think he's going to help them out but he
is supposed to be featured during the
episode so it's probably some sort of
post-credit scene like the rip hunter
post-credits scene from last week's
episode delance I was just about to call
you really I mean cool because I just
wanted to compare notes and I thought
that maybe if you'd like to come to the
ship there's no time I finally got
through the bureau's red tape and it
seems director hunter has escaped
what well where is he we have no idea
[Music]
there's footage from episode 12 and a
couple of the other episodes in here too
when they're dressed up like pirates on
that ship there that's episode 12 it's
called the curse of the earth totem in
the description just reads while Sarah
takes some private time which makes it
sound like she's not going to be part of
the episode the legends follow a lead on
the whereabouts of the earth totem and
find themselves in 1717 on the hunt for
Blackbeard's treasure so it sounds like
Blackbeard's treasure is the earth totem
remember there are six totems total we
know about five of them from the Vixen
series so the big MacGuffin this season
about all the six different totems
that's right out of that vixen animated
series if you didn't see it it's on the
CW seed the Zambezi people prey and
legend has it that their prayers were
answered in the form of five toilets one
for each grade Zambezi truck allowing
their bearers to wield the powers of
nature one totem for each of the
elemental forces
[Music]
[Applause]
water
fire and spirit
[Music]
there's the Anansi totem that's the one
that vixen wears that enables her to
channel the spirit and the powers of
other animals the air totem is the one
that zari has the water totem is the one
that kuwasa has the fire totem which
damien darhk's daughter possesses right
now remember we saw the young version of
her character in last week's episode the
earth totem like I said is the one they
go after in episode 12 and then the
sixth totem is supposedly this unknown
one that people don't know about it's
like this mystery totem that they
haven't found yet but episode 13 is
called no country for old dads then it's
Amazing Grace then a necromancing the
stone that actually might be the mystery
totem it might have something to do with
bringing the dead back to life
so maybe mystery solved then episode 16
17 and 18 we don't know the titles for
those but we do know that Wally is going
to be around for the finale so let me
know in the comments how do you think
that wally is going to help the team out
and obviously we still have Grodd
floating around through space-time so
he's going to come back at some point
he's probably gonna be the thing that's
going to balance Wally's power out on
the side of the Legion of Doom I'm just
calling them that technically it's like
a reformed version of the Legion of Doom
but because Wally is so powerful you
bring him on if they were all in the
same room together he could go into what
we call flash time which I'll actually
talk about tomorrow he could move so
fast that he could just steal the totems
from anyone in the Legion of doing the
possess of them so like he could take
the fire totem from damien darhk's
daughter the thing about that in this
situation like you make the reference to
Superman at Justice League like you have
the flash that's trying to outrun him
but he's just a little bit too fast so
he can see him moving out of the corner
of his eye that's where you bring Grodd
into the equation because even though
Grodd doesn't have super speed on the TV
show there have been times in the comics
where he's taken advantage of the Speed
Force or he's had limited Speed Force
abilities or stolen Speed Force from one
of the versions of the flash so I have a
feeling just because during season 3
they weren't able to completely take
down gorilla grodd's army without the
help of so lebar Wally will have some
problems trying to run roughshod over a
Grodd like you'll probably have some
similar moments that he had with Barry
like where he just grabs his fist and
flings him around a little bit before
Wally figures out how to fight him
so let me know in the comments what do
you actually want to see from Wally West
fighting people like Grodd and the
Legion of Doom obviously there's gonna
be a lot of funny moments when he first
comes on because they'd be like holy
[ __ ] we have a flash this is amazing
look at how fast he is because usually
when you bring on characters like that
first they have some funny moments where
he's like hey I'm the flash I have these
crazy powers I'll just take care of all
this for you guys but then there's some
hilarious surprise that prevents them
from doing that so we're just really
curious to see how the writers handle
that because I think the thing here is
obviously they're trying to fix time in
wall-e himself has not spent a lot of
time using his powers to time-travel
even though given enough time he could
do that just like Barry just that he's
never done it before usually takes a
little while for Flash's to learn new
abilities so hopefully he learned
something new that he never knew how to
do before he comes back to the flash TV
show at the end of the season speaking
of which if you guys didn't know they
just confirmed the Jay Garrick and Jesse
quick are coming back for episode 15 of
the flash I'll do a video for that
tomorrow because the episode is called
flash time they're introducing a new
Speed Force concept so I'll do a video
for that it's actually gonna be really
really cool
what'll happen is I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post that video but click
here for my flash family video and click
here for the new infinity war promo and
learn about the infinity gems thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight